this is one of those movies you watch
and then you reflector like what does
the control room of my mind look like
I'm not gonna lie to you guys
mine's probably super scary you don't
want to see this much rather watch this
movie that's a fact inside out so inside
outs the newest Pixar movie inside out
revolves around an 11-year old girl
named Riley her family has uprooted and
moved to San Francisco so this is a very
stressful time for her inside out takes
place inside the control room of her
mind and Manning the control room of her
mind are the emotion joy anger fear
disgust and sadness and ultimately Joey
has to go on an adventure in the
recesses of her subconscious it just
takes her all around the world that's
constructed to represent her mind and
all the other emotions are trying to do
their best to kind of keep her emotional
state stable but it just doesn't always
work out that way which is so smart it's
so interesting the metaphors and
parables in the situational circumstance
that happened to ultimately explain an
emotional state how a happy memory turns
into a sad memory oh you're kind of in
the zone sometimes then you just like
off your game the movie does it so well
I'm so smart the only word I can
describe it is genius this is a genius
movie I love this energy that all the
emotions had in this movie I loved the
interaction I love Lu's blackest anger
perfect casting to represent anger and
although he's a standout all the
emotions do their job in this movie so
well and the movie has a great lesson
behind it not gonna tell you what it is
you're gonna watch the movie to get it
dude I'm not ruin it for a better show
do you think this is I found myself
laughing so much in this movie but
sometimes it was because the movie was
being funny sometimes it was just like
oh my gosh that makes so much sense so
what goes on in the recesses of
someone's mind you can't help but just
applaud the makers of this movie in that
I feel like adults are gonna like this
movie more than kids it's a rarity among
animated films but it does exist
seriously kids are gonna enjoy the
adventure you know like Joy's going on
her adventure with sadness and you see
all the different lands that represent
her emotional states and her core
memories and kids are just going to dig
that but adults are can love how this
movie explains emotional states because
I mean we're all human beings we've all
had extreme emotional states and
sometimes they downright suck so it's
neat to see an adventure that kind of
explains it where you're like you know
that is it's clever
like in order not like this movie you
have to have no emotions if you have
emotions and you have felt emotions
you're going to relate to this movie
it's an inevitability it's undeniable
guys short review I get it but in the
end I love this movie I love the
characters the premise is great the
execution of the premise is genius his
movie reminded me of Monsters Inc if the
monsters Inc world was inside someone's
mind I'm keeping this review vague
because I want you guys to experience
the movie how I experienced it I really
knew nothing about this movie except the
general premise which you also know
ultimately finding a flaw at all in this
movie is just downright a chore inside
out fulfilled all my expectations and
surpassed them because inside out
definitely is awesome tacular seriously
it's hard to tell but an instant classic
is going to be but I promise you in a
couple years people are going to look
back and go yeah Toy Story 3 Finding
Nemo all the other top shelf Pixar
movies that people love along with
inside out ok so inside out have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more